And I want to illustrate this moment of finishing the history...
...and beginning the actual examination of the patient.
And I always think that a nice way to enter that moment is with the hand,...
...rather than reaching straight for their chest or their neck...
...which could be quite intimidating.
It's a natural gesture to extend my hand, they extend their hand out.
And in that gesture, which is very much like shaking the hand,...
...I slide my right hand further down and my left hand begins to examine the pulse.
And I'm registering things like rate, rhythm, volume,...
...and interestingly, I think, most of the time,...
...the patient also is aware you're hitting their pulse.
So there's this moment of connection there.
And meanwhile, my right hand is checking things like the warmth of the hand.
Are they vasoconstricted or are they very warm?
Is the hand sweaty?